today's topic someone sent me this story
so i forgot to watch it an urgent search
is underway to find a gunman who clayton
county police say
shot a youth pastor six times the pastor
says he was trying to help a family
friend
when her ex-boyfriend opened fire on
both of them the woman was not hurt
fox 5's angelique proctor joins us live
tonight from the clayton county police
department
angelique how is that pastor doing
tonight
well courtney he is extremely weak he
can barely
raise his right arm and he still has two
bullets in his body
but he is alive and thanking his maker
for that
i know i heard at least 13 rounds and
all of them were towards my head
youth pastor lord woods says he
initially did not
know if he was going to live or die when
he was shot
six times by a stranger a family friend
called him to this house on lakeview
court
in rex georgia because she thought her
car had been stolen
when the father of 10 arrived he saw the
friend arguing with her
ex-boyfriend the woman jumped in her car
and she and woods got
ready to leave you could leave and i
never said a word to him i just looked
over at him and i just
continued to drive and as we're leaving
out a bunch of gunshots
coming our way and we both just i turned
my head to get under the steering wheel
and then they missed them you turned my
head that's when i got shot in my face
i'm confused what are you confused by so
someone called him over to help him
i think he's just driving by and then
she and he saw her and she called his
name
as he was driving by why did he get shot
this is what i told you
sometimes it just pops off you
understand this was
one man one woman and another guy who
introduced it afterward you see what i'm
saying
and i'm not saying you did the wrong
thing by helping her it's not the point
of this sometimes
right we covered in the video why you
shouldn't approach a group of strangers
if they're
that was a one-on-one on one but even
look at the unpredictability of this
situation
right that's why i'm confused right he's
talking to the girl they're having a
conversation this man rolls up in the
car
she gets into his car the man unloads on
all them you don't
know who you're dealing with he didn't
know the person he didn't know the
person
but that's how it ended up imagine you
see an
argument you pick someone up and you get
shot if you aren't used to these kinds
of environments you don't know what it
is that you're dealing with
people who might be looking real normal
you
this is what i suspect happened this is
just hypothetical i'm just throwing this
out there
the guy got super jealous or he felt
some type of way
and he's like yo who's this [ __ ] and
you just it on both of them
there's people who were a couple of
screw slips
you wanna know why i know this man's got
a couple screws loose watch
woods wrecked his car trying to get help
he realized he couldn't make it to the
hospital
and crashed at a nearby police station
do you know
the man who shot you i don't know at all
i don't know and the lie detector
determined
that is a lie your family friend's
boyfriend
you don't know that's what you say so
you don't get retaliation or whatever
kind of affiliation you have but you
don't know him you believe that he
doesn't know him
i don't know you believe that he doesn't
know him i don't know i wasn't
hey listen when you live in certain
areas and you're a youth pastor you know
somebody that knows everybody if you
wanted to know who that person was you'd
find out right away but he doesn't want
to know
exactly maybe he doesn't know and he
doesn't want to know
that but it comes down to the same thing
it comes down to the same thing it's not
normal life where you would get
information on whoever did something to
you
in these kinds of environments you don't
talk true
what do you think he's going to say his
name on television no snitch
so yeah do you know the man yeah it was
robert dawson
bro and then bruh and this one
showed us his injuries after spending
almost two weeks at grady hospital
the 29 year old father is the only
breadwinner in his family
today is one of his children's birthdays
and he is really
too weak to celebrate do you think
they're gonna find him and i've never
been a person to not work
and everybody you know and everybody
found out that i got shot six times they
all
had the same reaction they were like you
know you're not the type of person that
had rivals
another type of person to you know get
in any type of trouble
now woods is not sure when he will get
back to work because of that his mother
has started a gofundme for him
if you would like to donate you can find
that link on our fox five
now i want you to recognize how lucky
this man is to be alive
absolutely and he may not you know he
might get health complications from the
bullets that are still lodged inside of
him who knows
and now he's got 10 kids he can't go to
work and they have to do a gofundme to
be able to take care of the family to
feed the kids
imagine if you'd be gone who's going to
take care of all those children
afterwards it's done
this is what i mean when i say some of
y'all don't understand how violent it is
out there no but you're not brave abba
you're not brave you got to be brave
this man could have had a bazooka and it
would have changed anything you won't
know why
because he was driving away when he got
blasted you don't know how these people
are gonna it's not brave you're just not
brave enough that's it you gotta
stand up and be like yo yo what's gonna
do remember people were like hey man i
would just pretend like i know they're
gonna grab her away this man literally
knew the girl
pulled her away and got blasted blasted
he he shouldn't be alive before being
honest the probability
if you shoot at someone 13 times like
that at that distance like the odds them
dying
got in the car inside the car of the
shooter yeah no no of the
of the the guy who i shot at yeah
so we don't know what it is she does
yeah
so but nobody's talking because we know
and i ain't mad at you because people
are afraid of their safety
but you know and you can disagree with
that you could agree with it listen
it's a whole other debate my whole point
is that's the world out there it's crazy
it's crazy in some places and some
there's another a story
of an nfl player okay he was having an
argument with his girl
all right big argument something like
that guess what happens
she tells her brother her brother grabs
four three other dudes and they rolled
up on the spot
there's an argument that ensues
everybody starts to get back in the car
the nfl player goes inside gets his
rifle
and blasts killing two of them that's
one against
four and you want to go alone and try to
be do the brave thing against a squad
a 15 a squad
some of you are disillusioned about life
you have no idea what it's like
okay so i'm telling this to the young
man
if you're going to get into an argument
and to any kind of alter be attentive
know what's going on around you assess
the situation okay
because no i'm going
i'm going in head first yeah yeah
almost everyone who i ever got saw got
knocked out never saw it coming they
never saw the sucker punch coming
never did even though there were signs
there ace and bass
even though so i bring up these stories
to you guys not because i don't want you
to help your neighbors or anything like
that but i'm saying
do it smartly understand what you're
doing and even when you do everything
right
you still might get put in a bad
situation but at least give yourself the
best chance you understand
give yourself the best chance so that's
what it comes down to
you know i hope the man recovers i hope
he gets better and i hope
financially things work out for him and
he's able to take care of the family and
his kids
but i just think about man what if he
was not here and who would take care of
those kids
you know so i'm still confused yeah it's
a crazy story it's a crazy story right
i'm still confused crazy story i'm still
confused about what the [ __ ] happened
hey you should be you shouldn't be you
should be the one bruh
the world's a wild place the world's a
wild place oh
so anyways let us know what you guys
think in the comments you got your car
stolen
all right cool let me just go
and i make both fans bro bro you you're
talking like there has to be some logic
to it nobody i know i have a friend
personally
who is just in the wrong neighborhood
walking home
three dudes pulled up on him with guns
robbed them blind and said say one word
not blast your head off
there's no reason for that you feel what
i'm saying there's no reason
right i agree sometimes people just got
a bad day
no i can't use the same excuse no
shooter no no no no
no no no no bad days no no but no bad
day he just really had a bad day no
and then he had a bad day he taken one
down
they changed that song just to turn it
around
you had a bad day you tell him don't lie
you tell all this to say man guys keep
your head on the swivel be smart out
there be intelligent
all right um yeah that's it
[Music]
jumping